and its crew drank a little too much
wine would you do for the 4th and had
some people over who got drunk and I
have a problem with drunk I don't like
when people get drunk and people I know
people who get drunk here's the thing I
bet I know I deal with drunk when I
won't Road and there's nothing there's
nothing I hate more than drunk I don't
know what it is you know me I love
everybody no nude drive right we don't
get drunk no well I get a little but
when I got a deal with a drunken drunk
like that who's just loud and obnoxious
women men I'm allergic to it I've been
dealing with it for so long on the road
there's a yeah it's a trigger for me
it's on my brace ride to this girl and a
couple in the front row hammered talking
the entire time
smashed a nice right listen guys you got
a shuttle subscribe like thank God you
said that my I'm sure you're hilarious
these people paid money to see me do
stand-up I'll give you five minutes when
I'm done since you want to talk so much
I'll give both you five minutes we'll
see how it goes me would please quit
talking nothing drives god it's nuts to
me yeah it drives me crazy
so spewing out hammer yeah out there
people that love you so much too
sometimes people will like will yet
biggest run long can then just like he
gave repeat your jokes I get gay though
oh my god they get drunk eh yeah they
get drunk eh like I get drunk I yell all
about 5% Gaya yeah like 5% Han or
whatever does not fire 50/50 which means
I'm a full-blown game fit did what
Harvey Milk knock you are you my [ __ ]
diet is so [ __ ] different Brian don't
you come at me you've what do you mean
bothered why do you tell lose weight how
much weight are you travellers you're
always on a diet what that's your girl
bros be fixed what
that's my girl yeah [ __ ] you I was on my
way dude
what yeah I'm a thick e3c thick bro I
was reading this thing this extensive
study that some smart people did over
3,000 people and their base it off of
protein like foods that they ate and the
worst thing you need a steak as far as
the foods go eating a lot of steak
should be once a month this says fish
and chicken we know this right fish and
chicken mainly
when I say go what because the steaks so
having the red meat is showed like what
it does if you eat it every week what it
does your body imagine if you're a real
athlete they're like Rogan eats red meat
constantly every day I don't think it's
good to eat that much red meat they say
it's hard for your body to digest
probably comfortably Tina in Nigeria a
certain part of the world they eat meat
every day but you know who lives well
they eat meat I'm not saying me any
chicken fish no they you know if you
read me every night I can't deal with it
I can't I can't they're just saying
overall in the grand scheme you want me
to wake up at 4:00 in the morning
covered in sweat like overheated bring
me young boys last someone well I know
that too but no but no sweat man animals
well yeah give me a steak two glasses of
wine or two at 8:00 9:00 o'clock at
night I will be up at 4:00 like I'm over
here really I can't do it oh you know
what's fun where I live at where it's
110 degrees
all my C's out sir that's a good time
now that that you know when heat yes
that's how I slept last night
the way it's kind of warm in these Rhino
who's yeah dude
Oh sweaty huh I do I can sleep in the
cold can't sleep in the hot I've gone
off very little sleep guys the Rhino
cine sir that's me right there sleeping
oh my god it's getting warm in these
rhinos oh my god look at him dude
[ __ ] funny so funny that's one of the
greatest I don't give a [ __ ] or anybody
says that movie so genius I think
everyone knows that well this is more I
curious yeah okay gets on this song it's
on this song all right check it out how
would you knock do I want to we like
this I got a wheel kick
that was that was really do it again
yeah do you have much prefer the public
that sits with our string I don't know
you couldn't see it they did a while
definitely a string two grown men but
snow pretty crazy right
huh more time let's see if you can see
it even yeah you see the bottle move
because they're pulling it I know but
still you can't see a tornado well you
know that is pretty much dude she's a
she's a baddie heard she's a nightmare
to deal with yes and he tried to do like
a Facebook live or write it live and
said he was on there for two minutes
like holy [ __ ] it's like this is so taut
you can get the hell out reddit is I get
people tell me don't go on reddit dude
you get [ __ ] a lot of hate oh my god
I don't give a [ __ ] no I won't go on
reddit don't worry but I also I don't
care what do you like you don't know me
I do the best I can to be good but but
also I mean you know I mean are you on
reddit create an accountant against
those people are hateful
I mean they're all right hey well well
no because you're a famous actor
comedian making millions of dollars no
no one who's successful is on reddit do
it writing [ __ ]
do you know anyone who's successful that
got on a comment and wrote something
negative about I don't want to know what
read it especially you've done a podcast
you've done anything do you know why
comic I have work you think Kevin Hart's
on I like do that [ __ ] it suck well I
don't you know fur or Rogen one that you
don't care that's where this for the
Sheep this is sheep dude this is a micro
rapport poster this by the way so monkey
attacks on people
I guess happened more and more
frequently increasing problem in
northern India check that off the list I
would [ __ ] I would come there and
they get them I'd get a bat and bash
those [ __ ] monkeys in their head I'll
teach you to give you a kids
I'll teach them where the [ __ ] bosses so
frightened see how this get has a
terrible problem but oh here they go
that's oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
and then they knocked up down there
tightening the end their teeth would
[ __ ] her dude all right let me let me
grab you you [ __ ] this makes me
angry
does it yep I'll [ __ ] kick you in the
face you dumb monkey [ __ ]
alright 386 monkey attacks were last
year
all right dude Hawaii it's real died as
a result
oh [ __ ] was imagine if you have kids
yeah but I would [ __ ] am I just get
myself a 22 and shoot your face maybe
I'm dude I'm telling you there's a real
coyote problem where I live dude at 4:00
in the morning they get together and
it's like Lion King they shout at the
top of their lungs
last night they might been killing
someone's dog cuz I heard a very loud
crying that went away and then all the
Coyotes were gone
that's it I'll kill those monkeys easily
problem is that they are yeah their
habitat is is [ __ ] up I know what else
is a problem in India you know what else
comes in Oh
tigers and cobras leopards tigers the
big problem in India uh yeah but not
hosed out and not in so in Mumbai and
the biggest city leopards cuz it
leopards they come cuz I know they have
a tiger problem too yeah Tigers you know
housing cases are the real problem any
people tell you form alligators no oh in
Florida I don't know why I was looking
this up no all over the word dude
crocodiles alligators cracked up it's a
real problem
Rocka down storm dude a real problem
that's [ __ ] hilarious huh
so how did they anyway how'd they do so
they had special tires that would then
produce this like blue or pink smoke and
they drove their hyped about it putting
it on social media
only lawrence loaded because of it Jesus
crazy
yeah they ended up running in to grab
the passenger and the driver no one was
hurt the driver ended up being arrested
for it because he did this on just a
regular street in Australia
life is funny man well it's like did you
know the one cup a couple did the
gender-reveal party that started all the
forest fires they show here it's mm-hmm
do you see that one no generally a
parting shot seeing with fires and that
was one of the reasons we had horrible
files or how about right yes look at
this pass that stores ona remember the
horrible fires in Arizona it's cuz from
a gender-reveal party look at this and
that started like a [ __ ] look
forty-seven thousand acres burned eight
million dollars in damages Jesus that
kids can be like Jesus Christ dead oh no
damn the kid Phoenix but I named the kid
be a great name oh my god I've gotta do
something the kids singed way go Phoenix
is good though switch other from I made
her Jen wildfires Phoenix doesn't matter
spark I named the kid damage oh boy yes
just life man how about that couple
again they're crazy cars you gotta know
what you're doing it's a bummer but it's
life is funny it happened years ago
somehow it's funny couple got married
and was out front celebrating oh the
grandpa bottom is dream car it's a Viper
cool five hundred pounds of torque speed
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] know what from happy to
you're like just like what the [ __ ]
to the end at least you died like
together that famous that famous [ __ ]
story about the two brothers who carry
their mother all the way to like 440
miles that did this
show their love of their mother to the
temple so she can pray and then God
asked her what what do you want for your
son you know for your two sons and she
goes for my two sons never to suffer a
day in their life and the sons took a
nap and they never woke up from the nap
it's a gift